all right
[Music]
anibao yes
uh i don't know
i don't know i don't know i don't have
that how are you doing
oh oh
could you please tell okay how would you
like to be taught would you like more
conversation practice would you like to
work on a specific
yeah conversation i want to work on on
conversation
uh yeah this conversation
casual i've been watching some french a
french tv show
uh called uh call my agent
and that made me want to just say you
know what let me take a lesson and try
to get better at french
okay so don't worry if i keep asking you
the idea is to just learn french
i want to do a show in french maybe i
want to do a full show one day in french
so yeah okay
what
happened
united states
[Music]
[Music]
oh
all right
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
okay um
[Music]
um
i okay
where do you live
where do you live
hawaii
montana okay
okay
[Music]
who's your favorite french rapper
um
and how do i say who's your favorite
rapper in
in french
okay
prefer it all right
[Music]
um
gary james okay
all right how do uh
how do i say
how do i how do i say
um trying to think of what would i need
in french
uh how do i say
the french government should
stop taxing
francophone african
countries
legs
did
[Music]
francophones africans that's a long one
whoa that's that's the light that's
probably that's for
late government frances there are there
the texts
the government the government francis de
arata
they texted let's play francophones
africa
all right progress
how do you say progress
how do you say dog
she all she um
oh my gosh
how do you say uh
so uh
and uh
oh how do you say uh no dog dog
not a doll i'm sorry i
wear it well it's actually dog okay
yeah i spell it wrong
[Music]
um
as we say in french just get your feet
done
uh writer
uh and then how do i say and hold up
e
how does hold up hold up
um
how do you say oh yeah okay
just wait professor
they're longer they're longer
language they're longer
how do you say corruption comments
and how do you say
how do you say so i don't keep on
corruption
[Music]
um
[Music]
meditation
that's easy
why do uh why do french people
it's it seems like there's a lot of
do y'all you know what i mean
huh
is that uh what's the natural one
[Music]
um
uh it's uh
come out like yeah
oh yeah
um uh come on
that down where's the weapons
well
and how do you say
uh come on death on
where is the llama
like the animal llama llama
is it llama in that's probably llama oh
okay llama
like where is
it i got
uh actually i don't know this anymore
though
uh como
come on dead on
i'm going to sleep
i'm going to rest
right
down
comment it down
we're with
we're throwing a part out of connection
what uh uh
i couldn't see him anymore now all right
okay
the best rapper alive
[Music]
fuzzy media
i'm the best rapper alive
[Music]
just sweet just sweet
okay just sweet
let me ha rapper envy just sweet let me
wrap it up
just sweet let me yeah rapper
just sweet let me yeah rapper
i'm very
uh okay and then um
come on
come on that thong these
mushrooms are stronger than i
thought
i can oh okay
let me see if i said
this champion
okay
while my screen i got to stretch my
screen out hold up it's cutting out
to the end what the [ __ ]
we only got five minutes left uh
so let's do profanity
um curse words uh
just run through them real fast rapid
fire plea like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um damn
my day
putin
hey
corruption
saskatchewan all right
uh putin
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay and put on
put on by itself it's just
okay
all right
uh and then how do you
uh come on the thong
china is gonna take
china is going to take us all over if we
don't take a strong stance
or rule we only take us all over but
rule us
destroy um
foreign
fermi
okay
all right all right
well that was that was uh that was that
blessings